for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out Mufi
University com
thank you and enjoy so next up is the
ionic size or ionic radius and this is
really isn't too much different from
atomic radius except that we're not
gonna look at it quite like a trend but
let start off with the definition the
ionic radius is the radius of an ion
when it's part of a crystalline ionic
compound okay an example of which would
be like something like NaCl right if you
think about sodium chloride right NaCl
it's really na+ and cl- right and there
are tries to each other so we can
imagine these sort of gray cations as
sodium ions and we can imagine these
green guys as chloride ions okay the
point is that they would arrange
themselves in sort of like a lattice
like this a crystalline ionic compound
and the way we look at the ionic radius
it's really just the radius of the ion
when it's part of this ionic compound so
if I highlight if I bring up the this
pink sort of depiction is the R - that's
the radius of the anion and the R + here
is the radius of the cation okay so
really nothing not really different from
atomic radius it's just that now when
we're not talking about just the atoms
no we're not talking about the neutral
atoms we're talking about ions that are
charged right so like I said you don't
want to think of this as a sort of trend
like we do with the others
simply apply what you know about ionics
excuse me about atomic size right the
fact that it increases going to the left
and down right and also keep in mind
things about the effective nuclear
charge as well as shielding and build
off of that when you when you go through
this
so really the question is what's going
on with cations what's going on with
anions so when compared to their parent
atoms cations are smaller okay why is
that
well if something is a cation its
positively charged its positively
charged because it lost an electron or
lost electrons so there are less
electrons okay in a cation then as
compared to their parent atom right it
lost electron so that now they have less
electrons they have less electrons that
means there's less shielding right if
there's less shielding yeah the
electrons aren't repelling from each
other nearly as much and and there's not
that many of them then the effective
nuclear charge right the positive charge
that the electrons feel is higher right
because there's less electrons there to
to pull on that that positive charge so
if the effective nuclear charge is
higher this means that the electrons are
pulled closer to the nucleus the
electrons that are that are still there
in the ion right and they're gonna be
pulled closer to the nucleus thus making
the cation smaller okay so we can think
of na plus vs na right so na is the
neutral atom okay and na plus is the
cation let's think about the number of
protons each other each of them has and
the number of electrons each has well
they're both sodium so if you look on a
periodic table the atomic number is 11
okay they each have 11 protons and
sodium being that it's neutral has just
as many electrons as it does protons to
balance out the charge 11 an A+ though
sodium ion lost an electron so it only
has 10 electrons so what's happening is
that in the atom these protons these 11
protons are pulling on these 11
electrons with a certain effective
nuclear charge right effective charge
but the cation when it has one
electron the effect that these 11
positive charges have on on these
electrons is now greater right they're
pulling those 10 in closer and so
between these two the NA plus is smaller
okay now as far as anions go anions
compared to their parent atoms this
should say parents not parents when
compared to their parent atoms and ions
are bigger okay and anions are
negatively charged because they gained
electrons so there's more electrons so
if there's more electrons there's gonna
be more shielding and the electrons will
be repelled by the inner electrons a
little bit more thus and so the positive
charges in the nucleus can't pull on
them as much so the effective nuclear
charge decreases and so the electrons
are not pulled in closer to the nucleus
so instead they kind of go out a little
bit and so the anion is bigger so here
what do you think about the same same
idea here number of protons versus
number of electrons both of them are
chlorines so they each have 17 protons
right that's just the atomic number and
the chlorine atom has 17 electrons but
the the chlorine anion has one more
electron should be 18 so the the effect
that these 17 protons have on the 18
electrons is not as much as it as it was
here right the effective nuclear charge
initially was between 17 protons and 17
electrons but if there's one more
electron to pull in the Frog those
protons can't quite pull them in in the
same way or not as close so in this case
what happens is that the chlorine ion is
bigger because it's an anion so let's
try these three practice problems
ranking
what what's given from smallest to
largest and let's apply the same idea so
if you look at l2 minus F minus any na
plus mg they're all different they are
all different in their nuclei right they
have a different number of protons for
each of these the number of protons in
each of these oxygen has eight right so
Tomic numbers eight fluorine who's got
nine neons got ten sodium has 11 and
magnesium has 12 but if we look at the
number of electrons they have if you
count up four oxygen oxygen gained two
so it's gonna have two more than eight
which would be 10 fluorine its atom gain
one to become f minus so it's got nine
plus one which is ten neon is just neon
son ion so it still it has 10 electrons
just as many as it has protons the
sodium cation lost an electron so it's
at it's got 10 the magnesium cation
resulted from the magnesium losing two
electrons as well so notice they all
have the same number of electrons right
they all have the same number of
electrons they're all equal I should
just put equal sign between all of these
right they all have the same number of
electrons but they have different
numbers of protons magnesium has the
most protons so what does this mean the
difference between these is the
effective nuclear charge the one that
has the highest effective nuclear charge
is going to have the protons pulling on
the electrons most so this mag the mg 2
plus has 12 protons pulling on 10
electrons and they go down down to the
left oxygen has only eight right so
which is gonna be able to pull those 10
electrons closer to the nucleus the mg 2
plus so this is going to pull the
electrons in and this is going to be the
smallest and this is going to be the
largest right so if we go through and
rank them it would be mg 2 plus is
smaller
na+ which is smaller than an e which is
smaller than f - which is smaller than
Oh - - now if we think about this one in
Part B we got K + RB + in CS bus right
what I notice about these guys is that
they're all in the same column so I
don't even need to think about the
effective nuclear charge because when
you're talking about a group right so I
should put slash group column slash
group down a group or up a group the
number of shells in shielding the
principle quantum number that's what
dominates over as far as determining the
size right so if you look at these on
the periodic table K is right above our
be potassium are above rubidium which is
right above cesium so the largest one
will be the one that's furthest down and
to the left since they're all in the
same column is just the furthest one
down so cesium is the biggest and
potassium is a smallest all right so
that's their order smallest to largest
now between Fe 2 plus and Fe 3 plus they
have the same number of protons because
they're both iron and that is 26 26
protons each Fe 2 plus lost two
electrons so it has 24 electrons and Fe
3 plus lost 3 so it has 23 electrons so
now they both have the same nucleic xual
nuclear charge 20:26 protons but the fe
2 plus has two - has to pull more
electrons and the fe 3 plus does not
have to pull as much so fe 3 plus will
have the higher effective nuclear charge
and therefore will be smaller right
so fe 3 plus is smaller and then fe 2
plus is bigger so you would rank them
like this fe 3 plus is smaller than f e
2 plus
okay so and and these are both of this
the same element right the different
ions so now as far as successive ions go
it's worth mentioning that successive
cations are smaller while successive
anions are bigger right here we have Fe
2 plus Fe 3 plus as you lose more
electrons you will be smaller as you
gain more electrons you'll be bigger
okay so that's basically it I hope that
video is helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying